welcome to this video playing swap yeah
this is Matthias Mueller Joan I am I'm
going 2-1 score against him amazingly he
is always lower rated than me and blitz
but I don't really get anywhere his
Knight c3 g6 is playing maybe like it I
should just do what I always do here but
is he doing now actually taking 10 yes
yes haha ok let's see yeah this is the
the notable variation leading to
interesting player see how he does it
mmm this really I wonder isn't this
isn't just a little bit in precise with
a five-year 3 p-5
I don't remember been ages since I
looked at this efore I come when I just
playful and see what see what happens b5
get it here
this is ok this is really different yet
trying to recall something but i did
that simply don't manage let's see what
we get here ok g 3o Bishop e2 I go-biz
g3 maybe that's just too slow i don't
know this is an a5 is just just bad for
black but i don't I didn't remember why
this is just a bad move but I don't I
don't know why I mean I forgot it and
sometimes tricky yeah you know that
something is really bad and you cannot
remember but if you take too long it
won't matter hintay in this blitz game
let's see I mean I have a good center
but call those pawns are dangerous and
he's got to yeah he's got one more i am
it's got an extra porn let's see
I want to try to get t5 and now this is
France t5 now d5 ed ed Knight takes
Knight g5 made own age 75 hangs ok yeah
this is no I cannot believe that f5
looks very very risky ok I can take d5
this is at least working oh come on
let's do it nope not waste more time in
this is why I went g3 m it's often good
on the long diagonal when b5 was played
I mean I didn't see any of this line of
course but it's it's very often
advisable to put it on the long diagonal
it's just the best possible square and
often yeah allows this kind of technical
ideas ok um yeah why not what's its
roots III Hanks but i have ninety-seven
or Bishop d4 first this is actually
interesting the Queen does not have that
many squares check on e seven
I can also start with this check and
just take this thing on aid he has some
problem with their five point as well
it's not clear Hawaii should go king of
seven I even have a I can you know a g6
and win when they exchange that way
which may be preferable I guess I better
keep the the bishop ok and now I just
take it or not check yep let's just just
grab it I don't know G for trying to use
this situation the spinning situation my
look is not playing in this is not good
and wait all the others first for Bishop
you form those pawns are some problem
quite clearly but please
should be six c3b sure i think i'm
picking them up always tritium but i
think i'll pick them up Bishop coming to
see three
trying to be as active as possible maybe
going for Rookie seven if possible ah
this one but I can take right and I can
take black resigns yeah i know i think i
forgot what to do against a five I think
this is a really strange move order I
think III right there is something wrong
with this move on I think it is or is
this just a transposition this is a
transposition to the normal to the
northern Noteboom um I thought that this
has backed a drawback against III
there's b5 that's clear but I thought a
five against be sure to there is some
problem with it well I don't know maybe
I'm confusing things he had so it's
questionable if I really have enough
compensation I have some with the with
the center but it's not it's not great
or anything yeah d 5 is now an issue and
each 6d 5 is a threat it really is and
this is really wow plus 5 plus 5 gives
the computer gifts that's amazing so
this this this night h4 is also also
winning with this it is quite a quite
sufficient Bishop c6 also good yeah yeah
it is a case where I'm check almost
every move will win but its its various
degrees of the how convincing it is this
is so convincing here okay I can take
these we take a five I saw that but I
had this idea that Bishop before might
be good check should be form okay eight
hiya computer wants to defend with this
which is quite interesting with this
now this gets its get somewhat tricky if
we look at this those pawns are
dangerous definitely hmm yeah it wasn't
this one totally convincing and here I'm
picking up everything rupee eight is
better rookie to it should win in the
long run I have the wrong bishop no no I
have the right bishop I'm sorry sorry
mmm yeah it should win somehow i'm
surprised that the comp is only giving
0.5 because it looks like i will go with
the king and pick up the points that
rookie 2 is blocking the pawns that i
will just use the king weird okay well
thanks for watching